hey Vsauce Michael here Nyctophobia is
the fear of the dark
but there's another fear that's more
chilling it's the fear that darkness
will go away
op de phobia the fear of opening your
eyes light travels at the fastest speed
possible for a physical object darkness
is erased when light appears and returns
when light leaves the speed of dark is
the speed of light but there are other
types of darkness that can move faster
than light speed for instance a shadow
across a distance a shadow can become
much larger than the object creating it
but still mimic its source moving in the
same way for the same amount of time so
when a shadow is bigger than the object
casting it it moves a greater distance
when the object moves but in the same
amount of time make a shadow large
enough and it can travel across the
surface faster than light if you here on
earth cast a shadow onto the moon not an
easy thing to do that pointed from say
point a on the moon's surface and then
you move your finger so that the shadow
moved to point B your finger would only
move a few centimetres in a fraction of
a second but the shadow it cast on the
moon would move thousands of kilometers
in the same amount of time do it right
and you were easily producing a shadow
that breaks the light barrier but
nothing's wrong here the rule is that
information can't travel faster than
light you can't cause something to
happen somewhere else faster than light
could travel from you to that somewhere
else and our superluminal shadow is
transferring no information from point A
to point B sure point B is being cast
into darkness sooner than a Lightspeed
message from a could warn him it's
coming but darkness isn't traveling from
point A to point B it's traveling from
you to point A
point B at the speed of light what we
tend to call a shadow is really just a
cross-section of a three-dimensional
region the darkness you are causing only
changes shape when newly unlocked light
fills the previous gap that's all a
shadow is a gap so in a way a shadow
doesn't travel at all
that's an illusion caused by us thinking
that a shadow is a physical thing when
in reality a shadow is just the lack of
physical things photons which chug along
at the speed limit the universe but that
doesn't mean two shadows can't kiss or
at least look what they are
watch as guy brings two shadows near
each other right before they actually
make contact the shadows seem to
magically bold toward one another in a
sort of smooch of darkness what's going
on is the shadow blister effect and it
has to do with the anatomy of a shadow
the region where an object completely
blocks a light source is called the
Umbra it's the darkest part of a shadow
and the most prototypical part of the
shadow where only a portion of the light
source is blocked we find the fainter
penumbra but as two or more penumbra's
approach and overlap the combined amount
of light they block can be enough to
produce a perceivable difference the
shadow blister the earth has a big um
it's 1.4 million kilometers long that's
how far away you'd have to be from the
earth for it to no longer have a large
enough apparent diameter to block out
all of the Sun here on the surface of
Earth we are nowhere near that far away
which is why night is so humble night is
just the Earth's shadow falling on you a
you eclipsed sunsets are cool they're
beautiful to look at but look the other
way and you can see the lumbering shadow
of our planet our atmosphere scatters
shorter wavelengths of light more than
longer wavelengths which makes the sky
appear blue but in Earth's shadow
there's less light to scatter and the
sky appears darker during Twilight you
can see the demarcation while driving
east from Denver to Kansas City I got a
particularly great view of it
this is Earth's approaching night making
shadow the beautiful pink band above it
that's the belt of Venus it's caused by
the sky reflecting the colors of the
sunset behind us you've probably noticed
that right after the Sun sets and
disappears from view there's still light
in the sky scattered from the no longer
visible Sun this is what we call
Twilight and there are many different
stages of Twilight if the Sun is less
than 6 degrees below the horizon it's
technically civil twilight you can still
do plenty of stuff outdoors without the
need for artificial lights down to 12
degrees below the horizon we have
nautical Twilight artificial lights are
more or less necessary but the sky still
scatters enough light to be bright
enough for ships at sea to navigate by
seeing a contrast at the horizon between
dark sea and faintly lit sky down to 18
degrees an astronomical Twilight is a
it looks like night but the sky can
still get darker until astronomic at
Twilight ends not all nighttime
astronomical observations can be made
below 18 degrees is technically honestly
night if you live at greater than forty
eight point five degrees north or south
latitude during the summer the Sun never
goes more than 18 degrees below the
horizon it's never technically nice
places like London only reach
astronomical Twilight at the most during
these months so if you live in one of
these areas and you want to avoid doing
something during the summer just tell
people you'll do it tonight you'll buy
yourself a few weeks but that's slow
darkness let's cut to the chase because
we are looking for fast darkness when
scissor blades snip the intersection
point between both blades moves faster
than the blades themselves think of it
this way if you had a pair of scissors
with blades that were a light year long
and it took one second to close them the
intersection point would have traveled
an entire Lightyear in not a year but a
second no laws are being broken here
because such a snip would be physically
impossible as I've mentioned before
rigid objects don't move instantaneously
all over when a push force is applied to
them instead that force moves via
electromagnetic forces from one atom to
the next and so on down the line a
compression wave that travels at the
speed of sound through the material but
what if we ignored that problem by
allowing the blades to simply be
separately already in motion
well that a point of intersection can
still travel faster than light because
it's not a physical thing it's just a
geometric point and it carries no more
information than you could already
gather by witnessing the approaching
blades but don't count out that
geometric point of intersection just yet
it's the key to another type of darkness
that can move faster
and light when waves collide their
crests can fuse into larger crests their
troughs in the larger troughs this is
constructive interference but crests
colliding with troughs cancel out
destructive interference
if these waves are light the result is
darkness and in certain circumstances
darkness created this way can travel
like the intersection between two lines
faster than light
imagine these concentric circles as
waves of light the lines are wave crests
and the gaps in between are troughs when
they meet the points where they
intersect flee up and down faster than
the waves travel especially in the
middle which in the case of light waves
makes them faster than light
the superluminal speeds of these dark
patches can be seen really clearly if we
make the wave crests of one source black
as well as the background overlapping
regions where red peeks through
represent destructive interference
darkness and you can see how especially
in the middle this darkness races up and
down faster than the waves in 1995 a man
named McArthur wheeler robbed a bank in
Pittsburgh he was caught because his
only disguise was lemon juice he covered
his face with it he knew that lemon
juice could be used as an invisible ink
when writing on paper revealed by
heating and he knew so little about why
that worked and he knew so little about
how cameras work that he assumed with
extreme confidence that lemon juice
could make him invisible
- seriously wheeler is an extreme
example and was the inspiration for the
dunning-kruger effect novices people
unskilled in particular disciplines will
often overestimate their knowledge and
abilities instead discipline because
they don't even know how
they know how much more there is to
learn on the flip side experts in
particular fields will often
underestimate their knowledge have less
confidence in their abilities or think
that everyone else has the same level of
knowledge that they do what drives the
dunning-kruger effect is that that could
often the more you learn about something
the more you realize just how rich and
complex and overwhelming and full of
as-of-yet on answered questions it
really is George Bernard Shaw once
famously toasted Albert Einstein by
saying science is always wrong it never
solves a problem without creating ten
more Einstein didn't exactly disagree
he used geometry to illustrate how
ignorance grows faster than knowledge
saying as our circle of knowledge
expands so does the circumference of
darkness surrounding it learning
studying shedding light on a field of
inquiry also reveals just how in the
dark we continue to be how many shadowy
things there are left for us to
illuminate the diameter of light never
exceeds the shadowy circumference but
what's the speed of that kind of dark
the speed of the growth of the number of
things we know we are in the dark about
what's the speed of ignorance if we
defined ignorant as the difference
between questions we know to ask and
answers we have the field of Ag Matala G
the study of ignorance suggests that the
amount of things we know we are in the
dark about is growing faster than the
amount of things we have shed light on
is it a coincidence that the phrase in
the dark originated during of all ages
the Age of Enlightenment when Laban what
quitting's scraping from his
under a collection of magnifying lenses
he built he saw for the first time in
human history little moving creatures
micro organisms
he called them animalcules the discovery
shed light on why food spoiled life
didn't spontaneously come from old meat
it was already there we just couldn't
see it but the discovery also showed us
that we were in the dark about an
entirely new realm of biology as
Philippe Bordeaux has poetically put it
enlightenment leads to but nighted miss
science entails Nations what's really
cool about the expanding size of our
nescient circumference is what Stewart
Firestein the chair of Biological
Sciences at Columbia University has said
about it it is there that science begins
where the facts run out just beyond them
he says it is a mistake to Bob around in
the circle of facts instead of writing
the wave to the great expanse lying
outside the circle if science is a road
trip facts are the photos we take along
the way the fuel that drives it forward
is ignorance facts more like facts part
of the past not the way forward when it
comes to understanding our world no mean
why is obsolesce by asking water knowing
facts makes you right but the equally
quick sometimes quicker and most
rewarding prize is the dark in admitting
that you don't know everything but that
you'd like to know some of it
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]